how's the gum resumes Peter pack welcome
welcome welcome welcome welcome we're at
night too
I'm already struggling this is not my
hair is doing great though so that's a
place that's always up all right I'm
pretty I'm fairly confident she's
confident oh no no aren't sorry
it gets most like ass today I don't know
what the [ __ ] that's all about can we
just talk about how [ __ ] sexy their
underwear is I mean at least they nailed
that part at least get it
I don't please explain they're all there
it's not so much about they're all there
it's just as much about just checking
the [ __ ] air vents it seems like at
least that's my tactic and when it's
gone so [ __ ] well so far they're so
cute that you know what I ship them with
myself I love the cheeks they're so cute
they're like a giant [ __ ] tumor or a
pimple or some [ __ ] I don't know it
maybe it's just personal but I am I'm
very much into that stuff so I also
realized that you can kind of hear them
when they go to the vent
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] now I am
or not there you go
[ __ ] off me
pull up I heard one of them you see a
seizing there now
[ __ ] don't [ __ ] me all right I have
feelings thank you at least some people
have some integrity y'all cowards don't
even smoke crack what's up with Bayon
nice Khan thank [ __ ] loud baby thank
the love praise the Jesus the Jesus
child to be pressed then good doing it
brothers it's 4 a.m. 4 a.m. waking up in
the morning gotta be fresh gotta go
downstairs god I have my house gotta
have my ass gotta have my Assamese ain't
taking on and none everybody
[ __ ] off ready I mean Steve whatever
gotta get down to the bus stop gotta
catch my bus I see my friend get get in
the front seat eating ass in the back
seat gotta make my mind up which asking
to take it's a state get it I chased
your lives with ass it's funny that way
well [ __ ] what I I don't know what to do
with you if you don't think that [ __ ]
I'm sorry but I don't know 108 see
everybody my best friend my best friend
in the whole world my best friend one
more everybody one more hour to go our
God is a balloon [ __ ] where is he
I heard him laugh I hate the balloon
[ __ ] it's the biggest douche novel in
the world where oh god he's in the vents
ballon [ __ ] in the vent balloon [ __ ]
in defense
oh [ __ ] off [ __ ] off I'm busy being
preoccupied with balloon [ __ ] alright
box come on
he's still there you [ __ ] [ __ ] face I
was gone for like two seconds what am I
supposed to do eat a [ __ ] dick come
on [ __ ] me already it's been long enough
it's balloons my triggered world or like
what's up oh no I'm so scared
wait I [ __ ] did it I did it I'm the
best player in the world balloons can go
[ __ ] himself
yeah awesome
I fight that's awesome thank you I would
what it what is it is what is it is huh
I made the piece it is a smooth delicate
Otto hey buddy how you doing maintaining
all right well that's that's good he's
like hey you got the crack cocaine all
right let's do this
Oh
hey girl it's me it's a it said it's me
up there in the corner you don't know
third night doing great brush proud of
you I'm so amped oh I'm so proud of
Bruce I'm so I'm so I'm so I feel like
since we did this one we can do anything
anything and I mean I don't know what
he's talking about I don't know if I
even give a [ __ ]
I [ __ ] hate that guy
biggest douche in the world many jabs I
thought that speak to them what the
[ __ ] cakes ass I'm [ __ ] listening
to his [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] what way what's that all about
[ __ ] Steve came out of nowhere what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] bag now I can't listen to
the phone call anymore
like what am I supposed to do about it
thought when you wind down a music box
its startup from the picket oh you're
not [ __ ] me now I'm not pretty enough
for you [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ]
off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off of that
de da de de da la da de da de da de da
de da [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] off all right
at least we know he's gonna come in the
beginning that's what she said ha
why you don't like six well you know
Enders what are you your complete
without sense of humor you have too much
integrity for that type of load sense of
humor I get that at least Elizabeth [ __ ]
off [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ]
[ __ ] off this is Morse code for [ __ ]
[ __ ] off [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] off you think
you get the trick after a while all
right you're gonna [ __ ] me a one [ __ ]
off
how you [ __ ] up [ __ ] off the game and
I should just rename it that all right
the music box I forgot I always get like
cocky like I was like oh it's going
pretty well
and then I owed I had like 5 a.m. like a
barely made little night - how the [ __ ]
am I gonna make the rest of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
off [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] off [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off [ __ ] [ __ ] off but back off but
but but back off but but off of Earth
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] off [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] what like what oh
no
he [ __ ] my flashlight look at that
[ __ ] okay okay okay okay that was close
he just [ __ ] ate my flashlight you
see that that is some grade-a [ __ ]
bowl-shaped not [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's French it's more finery he wouldn't
understand you would never understand
see I don't even have to look at those
[ __ ] anymore [ __ ] [ __ ] off [ __ ] [ __ ]
off
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] off [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] off [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] off getting real
tired of your [ __ ]
[ __ ] off already am music-box nice meal
and he's gonna [ __ ] me in one shoot [ __ ]
damn it I was kind of hoping for it my
body kind of started tingling up a
little bit I was like I'm ready
take me sweet prince as long as that
balloon boy isn't nice day
really great balloon boy are you are
they are you a tip alumni don't say hi
to me balloon boy we all know what your
true intentions are hey buddies
how you doin there buddies we're best
friends right we best friends in the
whole wide world we best friends we best
friends see [ __ ] my battery again look
at my battery right now look at my
battery and tell me he did not complete
to just suck that [ __ ] up how [ __ ]
dare you
have some [ __ ] integrity I have some
thought for your girlfriend hey hey yeah
yeah I can be your girlfriend no wait no
wait I think new to new what sorry I
need to entertain myself some way in
this [ __ ] game hey hey oh yeah I can
be a [ __ ] [ __ ] they're in the vents
I repeat [ __ ] in the vent
[ __ ] lock off [ __ ] [ __ ] off oh god
they're both there oh gotta know this is
multi bad Otto / God very very bad in
English I don't know how you say it
Jesus Christ have to check so much [ __ ]
stop winding down this [ __ ] ass stop
winding down this [ __ ] ass that's my
new theme song
I swear to God if I die from this fog
[ __ ] off [ __ ] [ __ ] off [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] off [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] off [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh come on that's not fair man it's
it wasn't me where's that [ __ ] I ran
the Conan it were all right first leave
a like for next part and I will see you
in the next one as always stay awesome
bro